damit nimmt entschieden dass ich den
song kelly vor spielen werde
ich bin wieder bei mir im haus der wein
kommt jetzt in der schublade der
schubladen
guten morgen freunde das geht wir haben
neun uhr 19
ich habe jetzt eine nacht in kellys
wohnung verbracht das war nicht
besonders ereignisreich weil ich
wirklich so todt war nach dem tag
gestern dass ich einfach nur noch kennen
konnte aber ich habe ziemlich gut
geschlafen muss ich ehrlich sagen lassen
wir doch einfach mal der tag gestern
revue passieren das ist eigentlich kommt
der crazy was sie gerade abgeht hätte
ihr gepennt das eigentlich kellys bett
ist denn nach hause gekommen so
irgendwie keine ahnung das ging alles so
schnell irgendwie dass ich es gar nicht
komisch fand so richtig keine ahnung
bisher ohne wirz bisher war das eine
richtig geile erfahrung ich habe das
gefühl das hat mir vor was brauche ich
meine nein der song gäste das hat voll
spaß gemacht zu denen so vom nichts aus
so zu schreiben aufzunehmen zu was ich
werde gleich mal aufstehen und gucken
was frühstücken kann da muss ich mich
wirklich noch mal ganz genau umschauen
aufgefallen gestern bin ich eigentlich
so vor allem durch die räume gelaufen
auf die zettel gelesen aber ich muss mal
so in alle schubladen reinschauen und
sowas vielleicht hat das wird noch mal
richtig interessant in zweieinhalb
stunden tauschen wir eigentlich schon
zurück das heißt ich muss jetzt wirklich
mal aufstehen zu hause ich hätte richtig
los da für orangensaft martelly hat
leider kann ich hätte aber auch keine
von daher hätten auch bei mir ins sechs
spieler tabletten und eine mit gras
gering am morgen vertreibt kummer und
sorgen sechs von diesen tabletten was
machen die denn so sehen die finger aus
und ja natürlich ich habe da reinpassen
jetzt ist alles von hälfte glaubt dass
ihr sind die tabletten und die riechen
einfach wie so ein blumenbeet
wahrscheinlich ist das super gesund und
so aber kelly lebte fahrgast dem fitness
live dadurch das gefühl so spirulina
tabletten und fitness brownies und so
nimmt man die alle auf einmal
wahrscheinlich ehrlich ich nehme zwar
nur eine eine eben morgan kelly machst
du das
seht hier gar keinen bock drauf ok
lecker bin schon fast als nächstes muss
ich mir diesen mit glas trinkt matten 52
liter wasser hat das einfach nach gefühl
dass wir uns gut eigentlich so das
riecht wie sie ist das jetzt mein ganzes
frühstück oder kann ich auch mal was
richtiges es schmeckt original so als
würde man irgendwie so kann so ein
quadratmeter erde nehmen und den in mixa
packen wird ein bisschen wasser sehr
köstliches frühstück aber ich habe gut
reden ich glaube kelly hat bei mir auch
nicht so die große auswahl es gibt
hersteller käse so das war's nicht für
mich gar nicht so schlecht weil ich
frühstücke meistens eigentlich gar nicht
so richtig morgen ich werde mich jetzt
hier duschen mich noch mal umgucken
vielleicht an die geheime schublade
gehen dann mache ich mich auf den weg
ok freuen sich die stars hier mal und
mit was werde ich duschen in diesem haus
wird sich nur in peru gewusst okay nicht
mehr fertig gemacht ich habe jetzt schon
wieder ein bisschen aufgeräumt
dh ich packe meinen macbook da drüben
ein ich glaube das ist auch gleichzeitig
der interessanteste raum ich meinem
schlafzimmer und wird auch die klamotten
hier
wir gucken uns das einfach mal ganz in
ruhe an was ist hier zum beispiel okay
wir haben hier so verschiedene police
klick date night raw hat die jeansjacke
ist voll cool aber ich denke mal fast
dass wir nicht die gleiche größe haben
aber die finde ich richtig gut kenne
werde dass dies das ist eine sehr schöne
jeansjacke erste gut ausgewählt die es
noch merger von giulia einfach so ein
paar klamotten nicht so schwach ist
wieder so 2002 helfen
hier haben wir wo sind das soziale
das sind puma hier haben wir es ist ein
kino scheint so dass es auch ruhig sagt
ich glaube die hat jana auch die bluse
aber wir haben wir ein paar verschiedene
blusen dann haben wir halt stop ziert
tritt inzwischen ist es nicht mehr
komisch dass ich jetzt gerade kellys
kleiderschrank review dann haben wir ja
der schule hier unten oh mein gott was
ist das alter schwede tracy die leuchten
richtig das sind ein paar heftige schuhe
würde ich mir vielleicht auch zu legen
die schuhe sind tatsächlich sehr sauber
muss steht wenn kelly sich meine schuhe
angeschaut hat bei mir ist das nämlich
so ich ziehe schon irgendwie selber zum
feiern an und soweit sie dann einmal an
hatte dann fliegen die so raus aus
meiner schuhe rotation bis ich
irgendwann kaum noch welche habe und
einfach alle auf einmal sauber machen
deshalb sollte ich mich nicht lustig
machen darüber gucken wir mal weiter der
nächste schrank okay auch kraß wissen ja
dass mankell ist video letztes ist verdi
hat er ja so beate auch bestellt und so
aber das sind extensions wahrscheinlich
einfach ja extras die richtige profil
ein worten sie habe noch nie in meinem
leben glaube ich ein rolls wie gerührt
kommen wir zu der schublade der
schubladen richtig gut eigentlich so das
licht hier schon so perfekt fürs
was meint ihr soll mal reinschauen ich
glaube wenn ich jetzt nicht reinschauen
würde dann wäre ich einfach der grösste
[ __ ] auf youtube macht natürlich
nur für euch leute und wir eröffnen mal
die schublade
ok ich werde euch ist natürlich nicht
alles zeigen ja tatsächlich eine sehr
prächtige auswahl an unterwäsche sowohl
funktions mäßig als auch reizwäsche und
ich muss wirklich sagen das ist eine
vortreffliche auswahl kelly großes lob
an dich ich mache jetzt mal schnell und
dann schließt sich diese schublade auch
wieder ganz schnell
okay leute das war ein kurzer spaß aber
ich habe reingeschaut für euch natürlich
nur es gibt noch ein paar weitere
schubladen gucken wir mal hier rein
socken leggings und strumpfhose die
schreiben hätten wir schon mal
abgecheckt beim schminktisch wird
wahrscheinlich nicht so interessant
aber das sind so sachen die sind relativ
einzigartig für unser format hier also
so einblicke und perspektiven die man
halt nur bekommt wenn jemand anders
schaut weil warum sollte ich kenne jede
einzelne schublade ihres schrankes
zeigen deshalb bin ich für euch da und
ich gucke jetzt mal ein
wir haben verschiedenste make up
produkte
von willi luh einwegrasierer alles am
start noch mehr schmidt produkte wie
habe okay weil es da unsere special also
wir sind halt verlor und jede menge
haarspray gefühlsmäßig ist irgendwie so
ein bisschen vorbei ging scheinbar
schnell eine ahnung meint haley
wahrscheinlich gesehen und natürlich
auch kondome zu hause
ich glaube es wäre er dort keine zu
hause sehr gut erlebt das bin ich mit
dem komiker wenn ich sonst nur in welche
schublade hier direkt das ist ihre haupt
schublade ja zwei geschafft
ich würde sagen ich habe jede menge
sachen gesehen gucken wir mal weiter so
jetzt sind wir schon mal gekommen und
hier sind eigentlich gar keine
schubladen das heißt soviel kann man
hier nicht hin zu trainings trips und
das wollte ich mein leben dann schon mal
ausprobieren aber irgendwie hatte ich
mich nie getraut da bin ich habe ich
geduscht ich das fenster aufmachen
wahrscheinlich könnte mir richtig gut
vorstellen dass das hier jetzt das video
ist was die meisten videos bekommt
einfach weil ich bei etlichen den
kleiderschrank geschaut habe dabei war
das video von gestern mit umstyling und
sonst fast komplett next level diesel
wieder im wohnzimmer hier habe ich gar
nicht so viel gezählt ich muss
eigentlich sagen hätte sohn vollen
tagesplan dass sich die allermeiste zeit
eigentlich wirklich irgendwie im studio
war oder sonstwas und gar nicht so viel
in der wohnung deshalb ist es echt gut
dass ich mich jetzt hier noch mal
umschauen
ich glaube dass es aber tatsächlich so
ein youtuber problem chrome cromcast man
kriegt echt oder hat recht bei vielen
veranstaltungen einfach so ein cromcast
bekommen das produkt von google ist und
wir geben das dann halt einfach wie sie
raus an die youtuber da ist auch drucker
ist kelly hat selbst eine play sieht
leute und die idiotie erklärt wie man
die play sie an schaltet bei mir
wichtiger wird es auch am start ein
staubsauger roboter hat kelly auch also
wir sind uns schon relativ ähnlich ich
meine bald staubsaugerroboter wir machen
beide youtube-videos wir lieben beide
reporter wir haben beide unsere
wohnungen da getauscht ich meine
insbesondere der letzte punkt ist
eigentlich ein unschlagbares argument
dass wir uns sehr ähnlich sind will ich
jetzt schon dass es vorbei ist es war
wirklich richtig ereignisreich und so
aber ich freue mich auch auf meine
eigene wohnung und vor allem freue ich
mich darauf mich gleich mit kelly
darüber auszutauschen wie das für sie
wahr was sie so gemacht hat und
hoffentlich hat hier nichts krass
peinliches gefunden aber so was bei mir
hier reichen
das schon gibt es noch irgendwas was man
sich angucken kann hier sind einfach nur
so ein paar spielsachen für youtube ich
mein ich habe ja auch jede menge von
diesem zeug das ist ja mein kanal im
prinzip dass irgendwelche crazy sachen
mache aber ja ich lasse mir hier so die
hände von ihren aktenschränken da hinten
weil geht mich nichts an das ist ja echt
stelle hier mit so nem sitze dann kann
man hier oben einfach so richtig april
liegt quasi unter dem fenster und einen
blauen himmel das schon richtig cool
eine schöne wohnung hast du da muss man
sagen kelly wenn ich jetzt noch etwas
länger bleiben würde würd ich glaube ich
mal einfach hier so ein bisschen liegen
ich finde aber auch gerber kelly dass
sie so diese zwei etagen aufteilung hat
also diese maisonette wohnung war
irgendwie gibt es so ein krasses
raumgefühl mit dem mit der riesigen
deckeln oder ist auch vor der wichtige
punkt wo ist einfach komplett hält also
weil so viele fans ist das egal wie ich
meine meine wohnung ist jetzt nicht
zwingen dunkel oder so aber auf jeden
fall nicht so hell wie die hier
ich glaube ich muss mich langsam auf den
weg machen haben wir jetzt eigentlich
alles angeguckt was man sich angucken
könnte ab hier eine nacht geschlafen das
projekt neigt sich dem ende zu wobei das
heißt neigt sich dem ende zu
ich hab ich nämlich entschieden dass ich
den song kelly vor spielen werde das
heißt sie reagiert live auf meinen song
für sie und ihr könnt euch das dann
anschauen es war wirklich ein geiles
projekt und wenns euch bisher gefallen
hat dann tut mir gefallen das gerne
leichter denkt darüber nach mir
vielleicht ein abo dazu lassen weil ich
werde auf jeden fall weiterhin so coole
projekt ziehen auf meinem youtube-kanal
ich habe mir nicht gemerkt dass so war
es mir richtig richtig richtig viel spaß
macht wenn es euch jetzt gefällt dann
können wir vielleicht darauf einigen
dass wir das bald wieder machen ja
freunde
das war's ich gucke mich jetzt noch mal
um und dann mache ich mich auf den weg
kommt verzieht sie einfach durch los
geht's und ich bin wieder bei mir
eine ausfahrt zu meiner wohnung kelly
ist wahrscheinlich schon an der tür muss
ich auch nochmal mit dem taxi fahren das
ist eine sache die ich auf jeden fall
nicht weiter ich bin total wer geld für
taxis auszugeben aber ja es wird sich
vielleicht da und ich bin schon ein
bisschen aufgeregt irgendwie
beide halten leute jahres gesehen ich
bin gerade reingekommen und jetzt bin
ich wieder in meiner wohnung beim
überholen nicht wieder zurück zu sein
ist es gerade noch deine gruppe fühlt
sich auf jeden fall komisch an wenn die
kirmes na ja man ist so rein gekommen
du machst du die tür ob bei ihm ich habe
davor nie bei meiner eigenen wohnung
geklingelt warum sollte ich auch künftig
etwas technologisches derjenige der die
tür aufmacht wo nur ein gast ist dann
direkt so in deinem kopf von uns zu
obwohl es seine wohnung ist richtig
verwirrt so was mir aufgefallen ist was
ich auch ein video gesagt habe du hast
mir teilweise so ein paar fiese sachen
gegeben
meine brust ist immer noch das mit
langsam sowohl hoffmann das ist das
business die leiden einer frau das ist
was der alles auf uns nehmen den besten
männern die sich dafür entscheiden
robust zu wachsen und das bei ja ich
schlimm wäre das eine schlimmer als der
stille haus des gletschers und
vielleicht mehr wäre was ist ein mann
ohne beine kommen
das ist mein ganzer stolz sind männlich
beim warten an dem weg zu gehen
sie war sehr nett also die waren alle
total interessiert und ich habe denen
auch wenn die wärme kommt bzw
ich dachte dann wieder im gegenteil wenn
wir da jetzt stelle aber das war
wirklich cool also wir hatten überhaupt
kein problem damit dass ich filme und so
ich weiß gar nicht was sie am krassesten
sie war mit meinen was folgt ist mir
sind connecten und deshalb sagen wir
sind da hat ihr sohn ist kennt dann
gezogen so der hose muss gleich erstmal
den song zeigen und man umsteuern outfit
so und ich habe jeden fall dran sind
gleich und richtig sie eingekleidet bald
nach seinem geschmack nicht gefallen
dann bist du spaß aber so auch voll
krass und kann am gestern abend kam ich
dann noch ghana und war nach hause
gefahren und wir haben uns dann noch so
kurz gehalten vor der tür noch eine
klasse autos und der hund ich weiß es
genau
der hat sich dann auch die grenzen nicht
angeboten die man also
er hat mich schon als kind die aktion
wird hast du glaubst denn du hast dich
richtig einfach ausgetauscht bisher noch
betonen immer allein da im studio zu
sein ich war wirklich das habt ihr
gestern den ganzen tag so außerhalb
meiner komfortzone nötig sind so geile
sachen entstand wahrscheinlich dass auch
wieder mal irgendwie so dass man viel
öfter sich trauen muss aus seiner
komfortzone heraus zu gehen und das ist
eigentlich einem leben von mega
weiterbringt so man dann am ende
vielleicht auch wenn man sich so unwohl
fühlt dann aber so geile erlebte noch
einmal kurz vor dem g am nächsten tag
denkt man war das geil gemessen an dem
was ich so tagsüber erlebt habe war so
dass in der wohnung schlafen aber so
kommen ist sondern der ja das gehört
einfach dazu jetzt wirklich verrückt und
dann habe ich das einfach gemacht so und
damit sie auf machthaber ich bin kenne
dieses war einfach
ich finde doch du geworden mit bob shaye
könnte ich nicht gestoppt aber denkt ist
und angeblich man hat sich damals schon
gut gefühlt aber ich mache ist aber
interessiert ist noch irgendwas fehlt
ihr noch
alles was du gerne wissen willst ich
wollte heute produzieren wie schmerz dir
gefallen diesen song zu machen
das war wirklich schwer sagt man einfach
so da war ihm spielt mir den weg ab
ich sage okay also ihr habt hat er den
vor ort gemacht
wer hat denn so abgeschrieben also okay
das fühlst du dich so um einen private
also ja das machen wir was machst du was
ich schreiben und dann haben wir den
irgendwie zähler auf dauerschleife
spielen und dann hatte sich so was von
mir sondern passiert sich auch die schon
gerade geöffnet habe wie eine schublade
die findet man zwischen uns später hast
du ja hab ich aber ich meine das ist so
das ist richtig bitter ihre frage ich
dich sehe denk so max hat meine
unterwäsche gebetet jeder mensch ist
getan hat und sie für mich öffnen müsse
[Musik]
aber das war lustig ich habe schnell
haben wir gemacht und dann sah ich dann
auch wieder auch schon mal das merken
pauli sein wird wie das vor sich stehen
ja ich stand also ein bisschen auf dem
schlafen dann hat sie mir gesagt wie
wäre es denn wenn wir einfach einen
kleinen laden u-bahn sich genau jetzt
wird sitze hier und wir so fordert klemm
geben wird so machte ich weiß echt gar
nicht was ich erwarten soll auch
wirklich gar nicht muss es auch nicht
sonst passiert das doch alles
wirklichkeit des 36
sie müssen also verstärkt wieder einfach
so auch ein kreuz ist bereit
ich weiß nicht dass er bleibt
das sitzungsgeld 7
sie sind neugierig seien nicht mehr das
war das schlechteste teilnehmer weil
gerade diese ja und halt ist mir noch
persönliche grad fünfte ohrläppchen
[Musik]
das hero legs in folge
ich rede von kelly die haare sind sofern
sie sie sind von nike die damen ist die
sie macht die mails direkt von ihrem
schreiben selbst weil sie so leister ist
und dem kleid selbst steht auch sie
jetzt diese kilian heinrich die leicht
ist ein bisschen peinlich aber ich
glaube ich danke weil ich immer daran
denken
sie ist die youtube die kinder
ich denke an sie holen
wenn ich sie wiedersehen die ohrläppchen
[Musik]
was soll das
ich bin der jazz zu deiner lilly ist ein
opfer nicht heißt dass heidi und in
österreich hofer
[Musik]
das war den random light kelly ist
legende sowie hänschen klein aber ich
glaube ich nicht weil ich ja mal daran
denken muss
[Musik]
geil so geht es noch weiter aus ich habe
das gemacht und studiert und und wie
hoch ist oder japan und geige werden ist
nicht immer m w in deutschland gespielt
irgendwann erster ich hab mir gerade das
ist so viel text also kann aber wir
saßen also darum thierfeld richtig
minuten das haus aber da wird die
initiative ergriffen und habe angefangen
diese menge könne zu trinken
du hast mehr gemacht sie meistens
präparat war die burg richten nur rapper
sondern irgendwann der text oder wie
gehabt aber ich habe auch noch einige
zeit deutschland heißt dass aldi und
hofer finde ich wichtig finde es ein
bisschen das mega gut geworden ist dass
nur hören ich stelle mich in der zeit um
sich vor laufender kamera
die zuschauer schön gesehen noch nicht
mit schon das ist der richtige am
nächsten tag die hände sind drüben und
ist gespannt
am ende war es ja auch ihre idee dass
sich umgestellt werde das heißt wir
müssen gucken ob sie mit dem ergebnis
zufrieden ist es auf jeden fall wirklich
wenn ich jetzt noch mal an habe wirklich
sehr unüblich da niemand im vergleich
getroffen dass ich aussehe wenn er
theater berlin
markus noch nicht wie ich das will der
sonst so dass von panja weise die aktion
check und noch nicht mal ein fake
einstecktuch schaut dabei war sie aber
selbst unter 25 jahren einmal damit
anfangen langsam aber bis dahin glaube
ich hab gewusst dass ein bisschen
fahrzeug das wollte ich sehen
vielleicht fällt irgendwann
neben nochmal anziehen erstmals kommen
mit dem ergebnis
also ich bin echt froh dass wir das
gemacht haben dann lass uns
zurücktauschen und jetzt kommen wir
beide wieder freigegeben wurde
die rostocker einfach nichts mehr nach
dem aufregenden tagen ist es auch mal
dahin werde ich offen
okay die leute dann macht's gut lasst
gern 5 milliarden leichter checkt
unbedingt eigentlich hättet ihr es bis
jetzt schon auch alles bei kenny schauen
müssen wenn jetzt nicht getan hat weil
es ist aber auch die perfekte
gelegenheit alle die das jetzt du bist
watson und auch immer irgendwie und
weiter so dass ein und auch im abo
deshalb schaut mal vorbei wir beenden
denn jetzt vorerst dieses projekt wenn
ihr ideen haben wir das weiterführen
können was wir krasser machen können
anders machen können schreibt auch gerne
in die kommentare und dann sehen wir uns
halt rein